au beau milieu de la plaine de baud
voici la station expérimentale feno
field
cette serre en mouvement est l'une des
huit installations implantées sur ce
centre de recherche d'arvalis l'institut
technique détenu par l'ensemble des
filières françaises de production
végétale un site dédié aux effets de la
sécheresse les sert effectivement ce
sont des toits roulant qui se déplacent
sur des rails qui vont venir couvrir la
culture pour éviter la pluie d'arrivée
dessus et du coup on va pouvoir comparer
différentes variétés de blé différentes
variétés de maïs pour voir lesquels sont
les plus tolérantes à la sécheresse
des portiques eux aussi mobile complète
le dispositif ils sont équipés de trois
types de capteurs des appareils photos
pour un état des lieux simple des
spectromètres pour les évolutions de la
plante que l'oeil ne peut voir et un
faisceau laser pour l'examen de
croissance on a des nuages de points qui
nous permettent de reconstruire
larchitecture 3d de la végétation et de
voir la hauteur des plantes de faire une
courbe de croissance et de comparer
effectivement les variétés qui vont
maintenir une croissance malgré le la
sécheresse par rapport à d'autres qui
vont tout arrêter
un programme d'études en partenariat
avec les filières agricoles et la
recherche agronomique fixe les priorités
annuelles en 2022 c'est le maïs qui est
observé l'objectif ça va être d'avoir
des variétés qui vont peut-être avoir
des tolérances plus importante des
avoirs des rendements plus importants en
condition limitantes ça à correspondre à
des scénarios plutôt court terme donc
sur les 20 à 30 prochaines années et
donc là on va apporter des réponses
vraiment plus fine les données sont
étudiées chaque semaine des
préconisations techniques à destination
des producteurs de semences ou des
exploitants agricoles sont diffusés
avant même la récolte suivante